hey guys this is P peppers from candy
crush soda saga tips com and I'm going
to play through level 2 45 and discuss
some of the important decisions I make
this level it goes really fast there's
only 25 moves and there's a lot of ice
to get rid of on the left you can see we
have two big pink fish but in my
experience you're better off and this
isn't something you can do all the time
but in my experience is better off if
you stay working on sort of the right
side where the Bears are actually hidden
because it's a fair you know that way
there's less ice for the excuse me
there's less ice for the pink fish to
attack and you get more use out of them
so that's pretty much a no-brainer there
obviously to use up the match the color
bomb in the and the striped so now you
know we have everything cleared off but
we still have a long way to go because
those that I still has letters on it and
so we really want to just plan things
out and we want to want to avoid getting
away from this area when we can so like
we have a match like that that's going
to take out the coil and hit the ice at
the same time and you know we're just
want to make that we don't want to get
to distract it away from here because
you can see that the moves go by really
quickly in that case you know that color
bomb at the top is going to be useful so
set up the fish and match it and then
this will this will do a lot of damage
and hopefully we'll be able to clear out
these last couple pieces ice in just a
couple moves
let me make a red match here and that
will get things started then take that
one and there you go so you know like i
said the main thing with this is that
the moves are just barely enough to get
you through to the end so you're going
to need combos and you're going to have
to set those up and there's not a lot of
space to work out in the middle so her
in the beginning at the top because of
the you know the blockers so make sure
you take your time before every match
it's real easy to get frustrated on this
one and i know i did when i first played
it but if you take your time and you
sort of work on the right as good as you
can and then get those pink ones free
the big pink fish free as you go you'll
eventually get to a point where you can
make some matches over top of the last
couple pieces and free both of the bears
so i hope this helps please like the
video if you found it useful subscribe
to our channel so you can find out when
we put out new videos like this and
leave comment if you have any questions
thanks see you soon